hey luke here with the outdoor voice
youtube channel and i'm going to do a
camping catch and cook video
on my little skiff
well if i'm going to do a camping catch
and cook video on this boat i need some
place to lay down
and sleep we're gonna do something about
[Music]
that
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
and
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
now
should go explore a river we've never
been on before does that sound fun
your destination is on the right well
this is my first time ever setting eyes
on this river
um that's shallow let's do a plan b
look at the size of that snake hey buddy
you alive
oh
my goodness you are a big snake
oh that is a big snake well this looks
doable but i just got my boat repaired
from hitting a log
like two weeks ago so i'm not sure if i
want to go out and smash another hole in
it
it is sunny and warm what a fall day
this has turned out to be
yeah let's go check out the water bud
well the river's definitely flooded but
this
is a lot more doable i feel like putting
the boat in here wouldn't be a suicide
mission
here sit down on your path
you like this jacob yeah it's pretty
cool huh
look there's water in the forest look at
this this is absolutely gorgeous look at
all this flooded timber
but we're gonna go back up in here and
explore a little bit try not to bust our
prop
and uh if all goes well we're gonna
hopefully find a place to fish hear
something
nice big chunk right there well i've
never fished this river before so
i really don't know what we're going to
catch i assume there's channel catfish
in here
ako back up
thank you i love you i love you too bud
well we've been here about 15 minutes
and no bites so we're gonna pull up move
and try another spot
oh it's mine
well i ended up breaking a rod and
caught no fish so this wasn't my
best fishing day ever but anyway we're
gonna pull up anchor and get back to the
boat ramp
well here we are second week in december
and it's a little chilly out here but
we're not gonna let that stop us
i'm gonna get this boat packed up and
we're gonna give the camping catch and
cook video another try
all right we're all packed up let's go
camping
well it took a little bit longer to get
here than i planned and we've only got
about an hour and a half of sun
left so we're gonna try to go find
ourselves a fishing spot before it gets
dark
and uh see what we can do
it's really nice today it's like 60 and
sunny
so my guess is the fish might be a bit
shallow soaking up the sun
we'll see
i've gone about 15 miles now and still
not seeing much of anything
and it's getting a little cold i might
need to start thinking about finding a
place for the night
so i'm going to camp for tonight i got a
little bit of bang here so i can build a
fire if i get too cold or if i need to
stretch my legs but i'm going to cut up
some bait and check the rods out and see
what happens um
you know there was a few signals down
here and we got a little bit of snags up
close
but i don't know looks as good as any
place i've seen today
all right uh here's my bait i lost my
cast net earlier this week
so when i went to the grocery store i
picked up a bunch of
fish for bait got these uh white perch
here i'm gonna cut up
also has some shrimp in a bag there
current's ripping pretty good here so
i'm gonna use my big rods
hook that through the nose so it kind of
sits in the current aerodynamically
well i got three rods out i can only use
the rods that have more than five ounces
of lead on them because the current's
ripping pretty good here
so i've chucked them out one two three
and i've got the bait clickers on so if
anything comes along and hits this
i'm gonna hear it but these are all
really big hooks and really big baits so
it's gonna be a sizable catfish if i get
hooked up
put my coat on and this rod just got a
massive hit
i knew i was going to get here late
tonight so i didn't want to fuss with
cooking
so i got a nice big bowl of mamadoufu
here
ground beef tofu and this weird red
sauce
you used to eat this in japan all the
time for dessert i've got some of the
boys halloween candy
no we're in the fish it's still good
still good just tastes like perch now
well it's getting properly dark
and really cold so i think i better
start pulling out my camping gear
i brought the thermarest mundo king 3d
xxl
i own a lot of camping mats and this is
hands down
the most comfortable the warmest the
largest one i got
only seven o'clock and i am freezing my
butt off i'm
so cold i've gotta get in my sleeping
bag so i've got my uh
my bag busted out here and you can see
how i've got it set up
and uh i'm gonna sit and watch my
fishing rods from the comfort of my zero
degree bag
oh i can't feel my toes but it feels so
good to be in this sleeping bag
oh my goodness and i can see my fishing
rods pretty easily from here too so this
ain't too bad
so check it out this river is apparently
tidal
when we pulled up to the spot the water
level was up here
and uh the water's been dropping down
pretty aggressively
it's only 7 30 so i don't think i could
go to bed yet if i wanted to
but uh i'm gonna sit here and watch
movies on my phone
keep an eye on my rod tips and eat rice
pudding and cookies
and just uh just gonna relax a little
bit i gotta tell you though i really
miss not having my boys
with me here tonight but uh they had
school
and frankly it's really cold and i'm a
little worried about them sleeping on
this boat and falling off so
so it's just me for right now
well guys it's cold out here but it is
absolutely beautiful
i'm sitting here on this perfectly still
cloudless night staring at so many stars
and there isn't a single bit of man-made
light anywhere to be seen
it's just gorgeous my hung up rod's been
getting some big old hits
the lead is stuck and the fish has
grabbed the bait
maybe he'll pop it loose my best bet
oh broke off oh dang we had a pretty
nice catfish on there
hit that harder than i expected all
right got three rods baited up and back
out and we'll see what happens there's
an angry beaver over there he keeps
splashing at me
i don't like beavers i had to fight our
30 pound rabbit beaver once on a date
with my wife
beat it unconscious in front of a troop
of boy scouts
good morning oh i slept really well last
night and it was so
fun sitting here looking up at the stars
and
i saw so many shooting stars probably 20
or 30 of them
but the tide has gone out with a
vengeance
and uh our boat is sitting on mud right
now
so i am sitting here just building up
the energy to actually get out of my
sleeping bag
and do something oh
it's actually a lot warmer this morning
than it was last night
nice little blue catfish he is so
wrapped up
when catfish get hooked and they can't
pull anymore they like to spin
and this one has just spun and spun and
spun
ah there we go well i really want to eat
a catfish today
but this is enough to feed my entire
family for like two days
so i am gonna send him back
plenty of little tiny ones which i'm
sure we'll get into
i'll eat one of those well because the
tide has calmed down the currents calm
down a lot too so i can bomb it out
there away from the snags a lot better
hi babe things are going okay so far
this is lovely
we packed up we ate up now let's reel up
and get out of here
so let's go try another spot how
beautiful is this
it's just gonna be an awesome day
all right guys we got a long straight
stretch of river with almost no wind
and very little current and the bottom
is very consistent
so we're gonna try drifting which is a
great technique when you're not quite
sure
what to do just go and drop your rigs
down to the bottom
just kind of let them bounce along the
bottom
oh we got our first customer look at
this
oh
all right nice healthy blue catfish i
bet we're gonna get a lot of these today
yo check it out i've got the garmin live
scope here
this is a live image of what's going on
underneath that rod
you see that's my lead and bait right
there it's just drifted along right off
the bottom
if anything comes up it investigates
i'll know about it see look right there
see see that fish that's a fish right
there oh yeah that was just a little
fish came up and grabbed it and you
could see it going all over the place
and my rod tip was bouncing
let's see if he comes back well it
landed that one fish and i had a couple
other good bites but uh you know i'm
gonna try another drift
we're in another spot let's give it a go
holy mackerel look at this that was the
most ferocious takes
[Laughter]
oh that guy was trying to flip the boat
i'm sitting there looking on the phone
and all of a sudden the boat just starts
leaning over like
what the i think that's the biggest one
of the day
yeah it feels like 10 12 pounds
let's go try another spot
well you know i'm really having a ball
catching these big catfish but i'd
really like to catch a little one to
cook up
and so i'm gonna try these shrimp
sometimes i tend to do
better with little catfish when i'm
using shrimp
yo nice nice chunk of
shrimp right there
oh the feisty one
there we go nice little blue
on the shrimp ah there we go
that's what we're looking for switching
over to the shrimp did the trick look at
that
nice pretty blue catfish well i think i
just got my lunch sorted out
oh look at this we got round two oh
oh he liked that shrimp man these blues
are just
healthy and chunky well that was a
pretty good drift but i
am getting hungry so i think it's time
to make some lunch
all right anchored up in a nice little
spot to make lunch
and of course we'll do some fishing
while we're at it
whenever i catch fish i like to see
what's in its stomach and uh
so let me show you see that right there
it's a clam blue catfish love to eat
clams
so do carp
two pretty white catfish blaze
i'm getting ready to cook up my catfish
and look what's coming up the river
holy mackerel that makes my floating
fishing cabin look a little bit teeny
doesn't it
got a couple army surplus tents an rv
got a boat on the back look at that
thing
blackened redfish magic here
and get this pan hot
once the butter turns brown lay those
blaze in there oh
it could have been you all right
[Music]
to take this leftover rice from last
night
and let that soak up all the butter and
seasonings and grease
blackened catfish and rice there you go
crispy
blackened catfish with fried rice
another chunky blue catfish
you know this has been a really fun
project and i've really enjoyed this
camping
trip but it is getting late and i better
get going home because i've got a long
[Music]
drive
i hope you guys enjoyed this video and
if you'd like to see more videos like
this
check out our camping playlist and our
fun project playlist i'll put links in
the description
to both those things and don't forget to
click subscribe to the outdoor boys
youtube channel
because we put out new videos every
saturday morning thanks for watching
guys
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning
and hit that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching